Create a graph of the
linear equation 5x plus 2y
is equal to 20.
So the line is
essentially the set
of all coordinate,
all x's and y's, that
satisfy this relationship
right over here.
To make things simpler,
what we're going to do
is set up a table
where we're going
to put a bunch of x values
in and then figure out
the corresponding y value
based on this relationship.
But to make it a
little bit simpler,
I'm going to solve for y here.
So it becomes easier to
solve for y for any given x.
So we have 5x plus
2y is equal to 20.
If we want to solve
for y, let's just
get rid of the 5x on
the left-hand side.
So let's subtract 5x from
both sides of this equation.
The left-hand side,
these guys cancel out,
so we get 2y is equal
to the right hand side,
you have 20 minus 5x.
And then you can divide both
sides of this equation by 2.
So you divide both sides by 2.
The left-hand side, we
just have a y, and then
the right-hand side, we
could leave it that way.
That actually would be a
pretty straightforward way
to leave it, or we could
call this 20 divided by 2
is 10 minus 5x over 2
or minus 5/2 times x.
And so now using
this, let's just
come up with a bunch
of x values and see
what the corresponding y values
are, and then just plot them.
So let me do this
in a new color.
So let me-- a slightly
different shade of yellow.
So we have x values,
and then let's
think about what
the corresponding y
value is going to be.
So I'll start, well, I
could start anywhere.
I'll start at x is equal
to 0, just because that
tends to keep things
pretty simple.
If x is 0, then y is equal
to 10 minus 5/2 times
0, which is equal to
5/2 times 0 is just a 0.
So it's just 10 minus 0 or 10.
So that gives us the coordinate,
the point, 0 comma 10.
When x is 0, y is 10.
So x is 0.
So it's going to be right here
at the middle of the x-axis.
And you go up 10 for
the y-coordinate.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
So it's right over here.
So that's the point 0 comma 10.
Let's do another point.
Let's say that x is 2.
I'm going to pick
multiples of 2 here
just so that I get a
nice clean answer here.
So when x is 2, then y is
equal to 10 minus 5/2 times 2,
and the 2 in the
denominator cancels out
with this 2 in the numerator.
So it simplifies to
10 minus 5, or just 5.
So that tells us the point
x equals 2, y is equal to 5,
is on the line.
So 2x is equal to 1,
2 right over here.
And then y is equal to 5.
You go up 5.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, just like that.
So that's the point 2, 5.
And when you're drawing
a line you actually
just need two points.
If you have a ruler or
any kind of straight edge,
we could just connect
these two points.
And if we do it neatly,
every point on that line
should satisfy this
relationship right here.
Just so we get practice,
I'll do more points.
So let me do, let's say
when x is equal to 4,
then y is equal to
10 minus 5/2 times 4.
This is equal to 5/2 times 4.
This is equal to 10, right?
Because the 2, divide the
denominator by 2 you get 1,
divide the numerator by
2 you get 2, or 4 over 2
is the same thing as 2.
So it becomes 2 times 5
is 10, 10 minus 10 is 0.
So the point 4 comma
0 is on our line.
So x is 1, 2, 3,
4, and then y is 0.
So we don't move up at
all, so we have 4 comma 0.
And I could keep going.
I could try other points.
You could do them if you
like, but this is plenty.
Just two of these would have
been enough to draw the line.
So let me just draw it.
So I'll do it in white.
So the line will look
something like this.
And I could keep going
in both directions.
So there you have it.
That is the graph of
our linear equation.
Let me make my line
a little bit bolder,
just in case you found that
first line hard to read.
So let me make it a
little bit bolder.
And I think you get
the general idea.